[Music]
hi how's it going welcome to another day
of chess and psychology today I'm gonna
do a lot on my Roxy and we are combining
just a psychology with the end game
class that we have and I would like to
cover more on my Roxy and to continue to
show ends games that are related that
you can get from our offices end game
I'll be showing the games from here and
I'll be monitoring the chats from there
so you see my head moving a lot so I am
trying to oh I already have a hundred
people watching Wow guys whoops sorry I
forgot to mute there we go mutes Wow I
already have a lot of people I am very
proud thank you
all right so without further ado let's
start so marketing is very complicated
and the to me Mark C is the pawn
structure and so I'll show you this game
first because this was a very nice game
that I played six years ago but just
understanding the pawn structure and
understanding what are you trying to
achieve with white and just how
beautiful the attack can me so I'm gonna
start with a few of my games and then
after that I'm going to switch to some
of the you know the super junior-m's the
classics guys those guys and you're
gonna watch some of their games and
ideally wrap it up with how to finish in
the endgame so I'm also going to talk a
lot about different positions different
openings as you can get to this Mark C
so if we don't get to all of it
today I do have two hours of my choice
on Thursday that's
we can continue doing more mark see
there so hi everyone I see a lot of
highs and I see 107 viewers already Wow
okay so one of the classic ways of
getting tomorrow see is this opening and
ideally you want to achieve something
like this and so this is one of the most
classic ways to get to maroc see so just
some of the super basic ideas with white
you have to really watch out for these
diagonal so because of that sometime
soon future you're going to play moves
like this and move your rook to be one
or c1 so that's your plan for the Queen
side that's a one of your plans for the
Queen side and for Kings side one of the
big plans that you have is to not let
this guy this Knight g4 because my chief
whoops because my g4 is kind of
attacking your bishop and it's taking
over that idea so when you play Queen d2
it's important that you have to eat and
most likely you're gonna do short castle
with the pawn f3 there are instances
instances that you play at four but so
that's why it's plan let me take a quick
look on the chat and see what is going
on Oh South Africa I was I was in South
Africa in 2014 very beautiful country I
wish I did one of those safaris but I
didn't have time so that's why that's
what white wants to do for black there
are different ideas I'm gonna show you
well most likely black is going to do
short castle so this is a short castle
now for a black there are some ideas
with d6 Bishop d7 and starting to push
over here so that's one of the typical
ideas there are other ideas with B C's
and Bishop
seven and there are some ideas with
Bishop coming to e6 and in those
instances are where we kind of can
consider a formula so that's that's just
like a super super short of it and I
just wanted to share that before we
start to gonna jump into this game
okay so whoops alright so in the game
that I played e4 c5 Knight f3 d6 d4 my
opponent didn't take keepeth Bishop g7
early on and I know that taking here is
theory and in the game I knew that this
was theory and that that is something
that I could consider doing but I just
didn't really want to make the game
super theoretical and I prefer to see if
I could switch it to some fun structures
that I know better which for example
mario.c hi from India and Mexico Wow I
haven't India not Mexico yet that is on
my to travel list Barcelona yeah I love
porcelain I lived there a year you
really loved it whoa a lot of memories
okay so see for my opponent simply
played knight c6 but for example if take
take this kind of transposes to the mark
see a pawn structure that's we saw a
little bit earlier if for example let's
say d6 taking is a good idea because you
achieved this steel marzipan structure
with your night outs already a little
bit so that's also a good idea and one
of the things that I really like about
this marks a pawn structure for white
specifically is how much space Weis has
so you can play in the Queen side Center
King side and yeah so thank you
so yeah that is one of the things that I
was thinking about so that's one of the
ideas that Queen 85 to try and avoid
that perhaps but you can still try to
achieve the same idea it take there's 95
and coming back to haunt this c7 square
so wife is super active and I really
really like that
so anyways my opponent decided to play
after c4 instead of Queen a5 with d6 or
take knight c6 I have a high from Poland
high from Chicago Italy been all did
those three places really really liked
Poland hmm I shopped a lot there wow it
is I'm so glad I have so many viewers
from everywhere Italy Italy I will have
- there are other places that I love but
Venice was my most memorable one and so
what else did I ok so here after night
six what we wanted to do was I wanted to
take after come to Queen a5 Bishop d2
for example and this is another kind of
reaching the maroc C pawn structure and
the the position setup it's not exactly
it's not exactly typical because you
usually have your Bishop on e3 and your
knight on d4 and stuff like that but the
pawn structure is same so you can try to
apply most of the ideas anyways so
I managed to get some of my pieces out
like that I played this ashtray because
I really didn't want to deal with the
pen so a street to avoid the pen Castle
castle Bishop e6 and so now I have my
first question for you guys how do you
want to continue developing with whites
so that's my first question
and let's go to the chats while you guys
are thinking a little I agree the Queen
isn't a funny place Philippines
left it got my first asian youth
championship medal there 2011
Wow getting old high from France great
country Argentina I have a lot of
friends from there Montreal
surprising they have never been to
Canada I should visit Netherlands oooh I
really loved Netherlands Germany
I had my I've been to Germany so many
times oh thank you for your donation
Nixon ah thank you for my birthday huh
thank you it's very nice of you
[Music]
okay so we have a lot of different ideas
with Dirk c1 and Knight d5 so when
Bishop III okay those are all very very
nice moves so let's see in the game I
went with Roxy one mainly because 95 is
nice but I wasn't ready to make that
commitment I love like changing the
physicians dynamic so I didn't want to
do that just yet and so I left with Roxy
one but let's look at 95 for example 95
if take you have this Bishop III that
was suggested a lot in the chat and
then you change this pawn structure for
it's kind of like this that that's what
I was not sure about like do I want my
see pond to be there my deep on to be my
upon to be in d5 and that's the kind of
that's the that's the commitment that I
didn't know if I'm if I wanted to make
by with taking with epon or sipping and
when we get to some of the endgame
positions that are specifically for mark
see you will see that how it's different
to take with which pawn because usually
taking the C pawn is good if your rooks
are ready on C file and it kind of opens
up that bishop so maybe like Bishop e5
Bishop c6 stuff like that just
brainstorming so that's something to
think about but instead of 95 or c1 is
kind of more chilled move and after work
c1 I had this idea to try and play
something with like maybe start pushing
over here because remember how earlier I
said that this this diagonal could be
dangerous but right now my rook is here
protecting my knight my pitch was
protecting my night so that diagonal is
pretty pretty covered up now
well that's the thing like 95 all of
those moves are possible Queen c2
possible but Queen c2 night before kind
of worries me so maybe not just yet
so another thing with drug c1 is that
rook c1 I really like it especially
because for those of you who have been
watching my videos for a little while
you know that I absolutely love to put
my work against the opponent's Queen or
if my queen is under bonus truck I run
away with the Queen I that's ideally I
don't like to have that hanging on my
head so
one of the other psychological things
that I like to do in my game so yeah
like that's one idea
so Queen b6 what do you want to do 95
possible but be careful but your [ __ ]
upon is kind of also hanging so what do
you want to do was it possible to play
Bishop c4 I don't think so
because simply Knight a 4 and this guy
is falling down because that's a quit
Bishop attack with your rope no I don't
think Bishop c4 is possible
so after Queen b6 yeah what do you want
to do maybe think about setting like a
trap for the Queen
so nice a four is interesting but it's
not it's not really tricky maybe think
about it more tricky move if you're
suggesting I pay for in this position if
not there's a slight delay so yeah
Hillary you're correct
a three so a three is a good move but
what if a three Queen takes beat you do
you have any exact do you know exactly
what he wants to do
okay so a3 is very interesting and after
a three there is possibility to play
something like queen take speech you now
what do you do after Queen takes beat
you
95 is possible true but so the problem
is if you play nights before then if you
if you play night b5 black has this
Knight d7 and now the Queen has a lot of
room to go around and you can't really
stop that
so what else
yeah the other option to consider is 94
but what do you do have to take rooks
III will clean before and so yeah from
what I looked up it is actually okay to
play something like this but it's a
little hard to actually trap the Queen
because your k1 doesn't work and you
don't have enough enough Tempe to keep
the bishop safe and attack the Queen so
one option that it is possible is to
just do perpetual so that's one option
that's possible and yeah it is so like
in gay in the game one of the things
that I try to do just psychologically
without that's much like super deep
calculation is when I'm playing a game
and I'm sacrificing something if I see
that I have repetition I know that okay
so at least I have repetition now I can
consider something I can look for more
and if there isn't more but our petition
isn't the worst thing in the world so
yeah that's one thing alright so in the
actual game after a three my opponents
played 97 now what do you want to do as
white
oh the position after Queen takes beat
you sure
so I said if Queen takes beat you you
have nice a four and then you're just
pretty much do repetition and you can't
really fly you're okay one cuz Queen
takes your bishop and it is possible to
consider something like Queen c2 but the
problem is that the Queen starts to run
away you see the Queen now has these
squares to run away to so that was the
idea behind Queen takes b2 and Knight a
for now 97 so yeah
why didn't black take on b2 the Queen no
the Queen wouldn't be trapped if you
guys find the better move please let me
know
why didn't be a black take the pawn well
first of all in this specific game my
opponent was about like 250 points more
than me
so maybe path was one of the reasons
also there is still a lot to fight in
the position and I don't assume that's
it's everybody's dream to go in and do a
perpetual so after 97 I have a lot of
ideas with B 495 Bishop III stuff like
that so I considered the idea before and
my I think one of the problems that I
had it before was I didn't know what to
do after 95 once they take take and this
is a very very weak to try and save it
is I mean it is doable you can't try to
pull something off maybe but eventually
this is this is a very big weakness and
I didn't want to give that initiative to
my opponents with before so I played b3
first save like playing it a little spit
safe having everything under control and
dealing with the e5 square problem first
he should have played 95 because this
would have made a position more
complicated but he didn't
he went for 95 and I feel like that's
more of a personal choice because you
can't play 95 or 95 and both of them are
equally good and equally complicated
just 95 would have been more annoying
for me because I would have to move the
bishop and decide if I want to exchange
or not and then where would you move the
Bishop e2 c2 but now after a nice e5 I
know for a fact that I have to play
Bishop c2 because this guy was under
attack so it's just little psychological
stuff that you might not really see why
this might be more complicated than this
but one of the reasons that you can try
to see immediately is 95 my next move is
pretty much obvious but after a nice a 5
it's not that obvious am I taking am i
moving a bishop where am i moving the
bishop so yeah try to apply those in
some of the games that you do now I see
five Bishop c2 and Hippodrome c8 I think
he should have put a five already just
to keep the pressure over here and not
allow me to play before anymore but he
went for a c8 now now what do you guys
think I should do with white so now I've
asked a question what should whites do
I'm going back to the chat and 155 let's
see if we can hit 200 already
so one thing that I didn't want to do is
to move this trick first because I don't
know where district belongs this trick
might become useful later in long future
with f45 so that's something to consider
that's why this rook hasn't been moved
yet
to answer Brian Clark rugby one Queenie
a three nights be five it is but the
Queen still runs away oh yeah arkasha
already said that
thank you I'll crash
that's a good saying thank you for
sharing that Sandeep
yeah 1995 is was my choice guys be sure
III be careful see I told you that
diagonal is dangerous okay
so 95 and so 95 if Bishop takes with
what with which pawn do you guys want to
take
hi candy okay so you want to take with E
okay um well that's interesting well
that's also why I went I would have gone
for he didn't take the night but I would
have gone for this as well and so even
don't thing is still kind of a scary
this pawn structure is very strong and
my bishops are both looking at the king
side and the Queen side is kind of
already fixed there is not much to
achieve in the center and now I can have
a good attack in the Kings side so that
was the general idea and I could just
simply play rugby one keep everything
intact maybe Co for be four so that's
why he played Queen d8 and here I went
with b4 I think it was a little
premature and rugby one would have been
slightly more accurate but before was my
choice and now I decided to push a
little bit more for the center with
Bishop g5 and try to go over here so
after this we got a position in which
white is pushing a lot in both centre
Queen side and Kings side and it's a
very nice it's a very nice position
mainly because of the space we have wife
has a lot of spatial advantage so what
do you think blacks should do
yeah something simple you are correct
when you take with the epon II d5 to e7
pond and Issa the holy file is also very
cool so yeah you are correct
so
yeah Black has been missing her with the
queenside so one thing that my opponent
tried was with like h6 I think a five
would have been more strong to just try
to figure out what's going on in the
queenside
but he went with h6 and so after h6 we
got this Bishop e3 and Vishal III was I
like the idea because I could imply more
pressure over here or try to maneuver my
knight somewhere and I'd be pushed over
here so those are some ideas to consider
yeah so after that's my opponent
immediately played something like
English seven to completely ignore the
Queen d2 heading yes so now what do you
think white should do white you can see
that white is forming an attack in the
kingside but how to actually make the
attack how to finally start the attack
yeah if if black would work if black
with a five I would have definitely
played b5 but that would also give black
some ideas with c5 square in the long
run and I think it was worth it right it
does look good for white doesn't it so
yeah we could push the pawn push pushing
h-bond I think is a valid idea but a
little premature right now
Knight h4 is very interesting but I went
for a nice d2 because I didn't want the
night to just be on the way and I wanted
dirt so that there would be some
coverage in the Queen side so that's why
I went to 92 the idea another idea that
was interesting was Queen e2 895 just 90
h2 and I think I think if it was playing
me playing right now that's the idea
would have went forward with 92 and then
F fours but six years ago me I went for
Knight d2
and so something like this happens with
Bishop b2 but the problem is like you're
never gonna actually take this because
everything is covered and like what do
you do after with Petri or another idea
is what do you do after like b5 so
everything like you are kind of
abdicating your king and it's just it's
not worth this a 3-part is not worth it
so that's why we Bishop b2 rook b1 he
just went back and he basically lost the
tempie so what about Knight d4 we're 94
here and it's possible but I don't think
you would want like you wouldn't really
pay attention to it you could just play
Bishop d3 and everything is safe and
sound then next you're trying with f4 f5
so I don't think it would actually make
any difference in the position and for
example if let's say nice comes to a
fight there is always just take or I
actually like take take take g7 if you
take on c1 this is a very strong Bishop
and there's there are a lot of
sacrifices that happen like this that
you give up your rook for this big
diagonal bishop so that's that's
something to consider
yeah that Bishop b2 was really weird
this should be to them Bishop g7 stand
its gave me the chance to push for f4
and then do oh I don't want to give it
up so what do you guys think we should
do in this position for white
b5 interesting f5 good what else I like
the idea f5 a lot I chickened out a
little and I didn't play it in the game
but I would definitely do it now
oh that's what I did I played Knight f3
and then later on try it we're at five
[Music]
so
[Music]
we need one nice idea so let's look at
in the game I played Knight f3
but let's look at what does f5 turn into
I think my biggest worry was to give up
this this C 5 squared I just I wanted to
try and avoid that and prepare more
before I play f5 because let's I take
take take take it is a very interesting
position you have two bishops your two
bishops are very strong and very
centered and everything but I just I
wanted more positional rather than
dynamic and that's why I didn't play it
but it is a good move and it is
definitely a five is definitely worth
considering should be your candidate
moves so I went for Knight f3 after take
take rookie tree I just attacked this
Derrick and he just went to drink a 2 so
now what do you think you should do
so yeah but I got a lot of black did get
a little activated and I didn't really
like that idea but so one of the
problems right now is that you want to
you know start pushing a little star
playing f5s and stuff but the problem is
that this Bishop here is a little
hanging so there could always be takes
on 94s and stuff like that and so maybe
think of a prophylaxis
[Music]
be 5f5 they're all goods but I feel like
you still need a little bit more like
just preparing
what does prophylaxis evening so
something like okay the easiest example
to give is when you when you're worried
about getting back rank mates and so you
play like h3 to open a little room for
your King to breathe but there is no
immediate threat looks like group coming
to last ranking meeting you that's like
the easiest prophylaxis the example to
give so just to think a little ahead and
try and block upon its ideas that's I
think the best way to explain
prophylactic okay so yeah look after
good good one fragrance so yep perhaps
you and the idea is to now go for f5 and
so now the question is what should black
do well my opponent would be five which
was interesting and active but he should
have played King g8 just because if King
g8 i-5 still works but you see King g8
is taking this away from this diagonal
and then a few moves you see why it is
important that you that your King
shouldn't be in the same diagonal as
this bishop and also recaps you it's not
only prophylaxis it's also a little bit
tricky because see this truck is kind of
weirdly placed right and if I get if you
give me two three moves I push this pawn
I take this pawn and I pick your rook up
so another thing that I really really
try to do in my own games is to not
leave any hanging pieces see all of the
pieces that I have are protected with
something almost all the parts except
for this one
there's also protected with something
else but my opponent position this trick
is hanging over here and that's
something that you can try to work on
your games and also try to imply on your
opponent so if there's like a hanging
piece like a large going up here wow
that's a hanging piece maybe I could
pull something off yeah so that's why
that's another reason that rook F 2 was
white and that she should have played
King g8 he didn't good for me he would
be five so now what do you want to do
there is kind of a cool tactic and some
intermediate moves so if you can give me
one two three four moves on move five
you can pick the rook up
if you need more hints let me know if
not if you could give me a line on how
to pick the rock up the realistic line
would be perfect
chess grant how am I going to celebrate
my birthday haven't decided yet
hopefully I'll be able to get some cake
from somewhere
I like Cheesecake Factory but it's a
little far away so that's an idea
for well I think you mean f5 and yeah so
yeah you should start at f5
so now after f5 well the opponent is not
going to take it because take take
there's another check coming too so the
best move for black is to take over here
now what do you want to do
okay Samuel here correct
taking on g6 is the best one and after
take back you simply take over here and
now this is you have clear advantage yes
fragrance you're good to good one
so you see now whoops whoa you are
attacking over here and here so
basically these two are under attack and
one of them will fall so yeah you just
got there
you just got one on exchange so now this
the game is still not over and there's
still a lot of things to think about so
now it's White's to move who wants to
give me a move
Pizza I like pizza
well he didn't honk his ruk I actually
very smart
I took the rook and there was a nice
tactic with pushing the pawn and opening
to the roots with the bishop so not
exactly hanging there oh I think you
just grant so I saw a few Knight g5 the
Knight g5 is the cool move because if
you take it I give you this check and if
you block I go over here so something is
falling basically and if you move the
King I just picked this guy up so here
is that
that's why Knight g5 I was pretty cool
taketake check Bishop h6 now Bishop h6
you have to take Queen f8 what do you
want to do now while you guys think I'll
tell you a tiny bit of story so I had
this coach not the coach that some of
you heard about I've had different
coaches throughout but he was very keen
on knowing your where your pieces belong
and just like strategy and dynamic and
all of those big words and so I was like
a 10 year old kid and I don't really
understand most of the things he said
but he did say this phrase that I really
liked he said that if you put your
pieces in the right places basically
good stuff happens and I did like in
this position I put my pieces in the
right positions and I got a few nice
tactics out of it didn't I so yeah
queen of a trick f1 if Queen comes to g7
well least of all you can just take and
play we kept silent and my bike leans so
that's that's why I have to Ruth one he
just played rukka four which is still
pretty bad position honestly because
Rica for you can just take and queen of
h4 yeah important to do this and don't
go out hero and for you try to play it
too fast and lose the air you know this
is a not very pleasant position is it
that's like three pieces to a rookie
basically with one Derek so be careful
with that
and now now how do you try to finish the
game off they're still like 10/10 for
them theoretic okay they're like
eighteen moves left so it's not like a
immediate win but how do you keep the
advantage because you have a clear
advantage and so yeah how do you do that
oh yeah
that is is it I mean I feel like that
saying is very popular everywhere the so
I'm not surprised that Fisher said it
and the coach I had twisted a little and
said it's too so
Thank You Abdul of
I have one of my good friends from Sudan
thank you
okay so yeah like all of them these
moves that you're suggesting they're
cool because it is a good position but
g3 is the best one the idea is if g3
well you're just eating up a piece so
one thing that you should consider is
okay so in this position you know that
as white you have advantage but it is
very important to play accurately
because if g3 you have to consider
what's blacks but smooth
you can't just wing it so now I'm asking
you guys so after g3 what do you think I
should do oh we're crossing 200 viewers
I think that would be the record for me
that I've noticed oh no I lost you come
on five more
oh okay I will go back to recap on an
otherwise night of six I just really
want some input on what should black do
right now
Queen g7 yep okay so good you guys are
thinking about Queen g7 white and black
know so let's go here you suggested
Knight f6 well this is kind of what's
what happens if I just take oh before we
kept one oh you mean here Knight f6 um I
think if Knight f6 well would he do
after rook f1
how long do you have okay eight oh this
is interesting
so many interesting lines so rotate is
definitely interesting but what if you
want to just wait chill and play rook if
- I feel like this is also good enough
well what would you do as black because
I'm just taking up six with my whoa
everything
ah
well thank you for bursting my bubble
action a crush
Oh hold on my bad I was thinking I
already took here
you can't take here and give this check
can't you and then this guy is hanging
sorry I had a tiny brain brain farts
okay so yeah what do you do after this
because Knight f6 the simplest thing is
to take and to just play your case that
I know and you're just picking this guy
up yeah this this shouldn't be
okay so we are agree on this is good yes
200
no brain freeze okay all right so gladly
agree and let's get back to the game
here g3 Queen g7 now you would be
picking this guy up won't you and what
do you do after nice g6 white is winning
it's just a matter of playing a curent
back here and the curettes ah playing
gets accurate accurate oh my god I can't
say about it's just a matter of playing
get some precise there you go here's a
vocabulary yeah so how can you play this
precise
thank you thank you
[Music]
yeah drink G for your perk g4 is the
best one queen g4 is also good so the
idea is root three four is good cuz well
you're not gonna take this because this
is um this is a pretty easy winning
endgame and if you move away I can also
just get to this and this is also
winning so every g4 was the most precise
one but I went with queen g4 and I got
myself into this position which is still
pretty cool because if you take here I
would give give this pawn up but it is a
still winnable it's a little harder now
but it's still doable so so yeah he just
tried to go for Queen d4 blocking it a
little taking a pond and I so clean s5
is good whoops that is not good Queen h5
is good or h4 is good so these are two
of the good moves that you could
consider but what happened was that I
just I kind of wanted to exchange the
Queen's off and if take take this is
already winning position so I thought
that's a good idea
and if check now you have to be careful
with perpetual so what would you do and
[Music]
yeah
Wow thank you I will give your love to
Thalia supposed to see her Thursday
Tonya I am not sure when I'm going to
see her but I'm sure she she already
knows you guys here love her so
that the endgame with the night against
rook it is possible to win but it is
kind of harder so that's something that
I would have to kind of like pay the
price for for not playing superheroes
with Luke Luke instead of Quincy for
Luke g4 so yeah you can you go with king
each one 95 you give some checks and now
can someone find me some nice meat or
something maybe it's not immediate mate
but you're working towards that so any
ideas
well technically if I showed you guys if
I showed this to you guys as just a
puzzle and I asked you to find me mate
I'm sure a lot of you would
most of pretty much all vehicles except
for one of it oh maybe two of it is for
check so if you even eat the clean I'm
happy with that too
okay so yeah can someone give me a full
line
anyone full-line like I do this you do
that I do this you do that
okay so let's yeah cleaner shades can
get five now how do we Tod these right
to finish it off
okay rook g6 is interesting but what do
you do now
hmm it would make things complicated for
no reason so that's why Queen h8 is
better full line with pencil ok rookie
f1 is interesting but it's better to
play clean your 7 first because if now
you're putting here I can actually play
something like Queen g5 Queen g7 or
rookie f1 and it's kind of easier to to
win this whereas if you were to play
like work f1 first the king could get
some chance to run away but when your
queen is on h7 the King can't really run
to e4 anymore so now you do recap 1 so
what do you do after Knight f3
so somebody if after that Queenie five
if you exchange the Queens and you push
the age she also has the beep on to push
so be careful with those fun and games
yeah so after Knight f3 Queen h4 is
interesting now and then you do this
check over here
and you can't take and just play this
and this is winning or you can just keep
taking more pawns there's no immediate
threat
so if King g3 now you guys are gonna
love this move maybe think about what
would you do is wife these are the final
few moves so
kingi - I think there's a little bit of
delay probably
Queen c2 is interesting but maybe try to
keep the Queen a little closer to the
king
yeah going on five good job
maybe yeah okay so Queen at five and my
idea is pretty simple I am coming for
your queen
so either mates or queen and this is
just this is just winning so yeah this
was one of the games that I really liked
saying my Roxy pawn structure and I
didn't really have end games involved so
we are gonna get to the end games pretty
soon give me a second to pull the next
one up and yeah so these are actually
pretty cool games and I really liked
watching them so I think that's to start
looking at the end game ones already
right just give me one more second to
make sure that this is the end game one
that I want cuz there's so many of its
this is a good one I think
any of its from here is pretty good okay
so I'm just going to show you this first
before we get the end game so this I
told you there are other ways to reach
the mark C position so this is one of it
with for example Knight f3 and you do
see 45s and see if you reach the same
position and you got into the classic
mark C stuff so let me show you one more
I'm not going to get deep in this game
just because I wanted to show you what
is it's that we are usually looking for
when we say like you can reach Mark C
from different positions there was one
game that I played from
different there it was from Sicilian
neither see and you kind of get to this
marks upon structure again and it was a
very nice game I really liked it it's
just like marks upon structure without
this white colored Bishop so here is an
idea and actually let's look at this
game really quick it wasn't that
tactical but it was pretty interesting
and the endgame especially was kind of
weird that I still can't believe I won
that anything but well why not so we got
into some some kind of mark C pawn
structure but the opponent's plays b5
and we got to this position so you are a
pawn up but your pawns are kind of
weirdly placed and so after Casto for
example this i really like this idea to
try and bring my Knights maybe a little
jumping around and that's what I did so
actually this game was played in World
Junior Championship 2015 in con tomate
Sisk and I played there very well I I
think there was one critical game that
if I had scored higher in that game I
would have gotten bronze but I ended up
taking the sixth place so that was
interesting
what was my rating in that game I was
barely 2,100 just crossed it and he was
around 23 15 in the previous game and
this game I believe I was around 20 to
50 and
my opponents was around 2,300 so yeah I
just wanted to show you the how you
could get to that position like you can
reach this mark see pawns in from
different openings and that's why I'm
kind of going fast instead of asking you
guys to think hard on these games
because this is just to make a point and
should get to the endgame so one more
thing to keep in mind is these d5s these
d pubs are nasty with white I absolutely
hate them that's why one of my ideas is
always to try to have a knight that
controls a d5 square because when like
when black gets to play this d5 like
right now this is a weirdly placed
Bishop this good for sure but after d5
everything changes and after take take
take it kind of starts to get kind of
black starts to get active unnecessarily
active and that's what I kind of hate
key concept that helps me to always push
and to see if the post of what the
position has to offer and that's
something that I tried to do in this
game I really pushed and I got the point
how old was I in this game I would have
been 17 in the game that I showed you
previously I would have been it was 2014
so I would have been 16 yeah okay so now
you see like this pot is cool right and
the Queen is placed nicely this trick is
placed last everything is nice so that's
why black has to try and play kind of
dynamic and try to just chop chop chop
it a little and that's another reason
that's
you see this queen is also misplaced
over here you kind of want to bring your
queen back to the game see now what
would you do with white my first
question of you in the game
it's not that it's not drag yeah it's
not like a hard move it's just more like
understanding move and yes okay eight is
the best one take take King H seven now
now what do you think you should do I
made a mistake in this position and the
game could have ended in draw because of
my mistake but it didn't so now what do
you think you should do if you can't
make a decision between which moves to
play you can give me different candidate
moves too now too early to give up why
should we give up so World Championship
in I want a tomato
so um guys rugby one is a blender
no Brooke v1 just Queen takes c4 Queen
a4 is the move I played and is wrong I
mean it's not a it's not like a blunder
but it's not the most I hear it's one
Queen a7 is interesting but still not
the best one
Queen a4 did look very nice to meet you
in the game and I played it but not good
enough you need something a little more
persuasive
so like the idea with truck t1 wreck t8
is interesting but if rope t1 just
quintics p3 attacking the knight and the
rook so oh I see one shy hold on Silas
yeah childish I think you're the first
one to suggest Queen c8 and you're right
Quincy it is the best plan the most
accurate one and the idea is pretty
simple you take over here I'm gonna push
and if you go and take over there I have
this 95 and if you try to play something
like Queen before again again I have 95
and so my idea is simple I want to get
your exchange and try my chance in there
so yeah that is the simplest idea but
mic problems hair problems whoops okay
so I appoint queen a4 and after Queen 84
my idea was that if you were to take
Queen b3 maybe I could change and take
over here and maybe take over there and
push for that but it's not enough so I
would have still pushed but after King
g8 there is like not much to push for
honestly and even though you would
probably win this pawn it's just this is
like the the driest endgame I think one
of the driest and games that I've ever
played hand one so she played 97 and
here I should have played Queen 87 with
the same ideas like if you take over
here I could try and create maybe some
action over there so I could make that
game more interesting but I took and I
played rugby 1 she should have waited
Knight b6 but F 6 is just good enough
and here is when we are talking here is
when I meant to push because this is
like this is like a really equal
position but he just because I thought I
could pull something off and I had the
idea and I tried to play accurate I did
manage to get something out of it
I know it's dryish right so I brought
the king closer
so in this recount game so who is there
anyone here who feels super confident
about trucking the rook hands game
knowledge nothing
anyone
well I'm glad you do so you know that
this is a like a super Josh right yeah
so one of the biggest things in end
games and specially routine games is to
bring the King activate your King and
that's what I did and that's what she
should have done
she should have brought out her King but
she didn't and she pushed pawns so I
started pushing pawns and now it got to
a nice race but my King is more active
seeing if she played king g6 first
before she gets to she gets to bring her
King closer as well but in this position
her King is really far away so she just
came up and the King on the Queen side
and started to push on the King side so
I know this looks scary but what do you
think is the most accurate move here
to answer sciocracy well I I know for a
fact us we are going to stream the match
in protest like between the Archbishop's
and give me one second that I want to
say wrong sorry 20 on 20 against the San
Francisco Mechanics Institute there we
go oldest club in the nation I hope you
heard that so we're gonna kick their
butt we are so I know that Caleb and I
are doing that yeah we have the match
commenter e of San Luis versus San
Francisco
so some sands sands for sustains so I
know we have that sorry for the purchase
League glitch whoops but I know we're
doing that from 6:30 to 9:30 our time
and here's the link Thank You Ben so
yeah yeah rook p3 is the most accurate
so if you start pushing King c6 blacks
also pushing and whoops not that much
pushing but you get the idea right black
gets really comfortable so as white as a
chess player it's your job to make your
opponent's life over the board's kind of
miserable and so that's why you go with
rook b3 first you don't want to make
things easy for your opponent so you
play with b3 to cut the king a little
and you push the pawn first see the king
is still not getting in the pawns are
still not getting in
and after h5 now you go with the king so
it's just a matter of which move to play
first Tim Olson we do play man in chess
that is a very interesting comment of
course we do
and okay so after king d4
chinga King making a queen now what do
you guys think I'm gonna make it and I'm
going to get to this race and win the
game well I've already said I won the
game but do you think um
well I kind of blew it but maybe
calculated a little no no not to not to
insult them like over the chessboard
with chess pieces like don't let your
opponents just easily come and meet you
make it hard for them thank you sire
crush for the detailed explanation and
thank you Tim Wilson for that comment a
little weird but it is true it's it's
not that it's wrong it's weird that's
like we have to say that but thank you
for knowing and acknowledging that
okay so eventually ideally you want to
be able to keep the rook but it is
unlikely that you will manage to keep
the rook and that's why you try your
best to bring the King as fast as you
can and now that the tiny problem is you
can't really bring the King closer so
you can try to bring the king from
behind the rook and now this is a
winning ponent game right you guys
remember your palm and games classes
with me you guys King up King up take
take and voila
even if King Gary doesn't really matter
as soon as you take it this is this pawn
is going that way and that's the super
win so that was another game that I
wanted to share with you now I'm gonna
show you another game that I played
again in neither F but I'm not going to
go into details about that I'm just
showing you the openings that ha could
reach to my Roxy so it's another one I
play this in World Youth Championship
2015 against BB Sarah she played her
Kazakh stance which to Russia naturist
researched back to Kazakhstan but at the
time when I played her I think she was
playing for Kazakhstan and yeah so
remember in the last game
my opponent Irina she played 97 right
now we got Sadat marks upon structure
but with Bishop d7 we can also get to
that position and I'm just going to show
you a little bit more because my idea is
to just show you see you got that exact
mark Zupan structure you got your rook
out you got your castle and the only
Frances that e to Bishop and d7 Bishop
are exchanged off and you start to
maneuver around a little so that's
another game that I wanted to show you
and I'm not gonna go into details
because I want to show you some cool end
games if you guys would like to see more
mark C we could maybe put up it put it
up again for votes like with it last
week then we can go to more depth with
maroc see and look at more games on our
Thursday because you're gonna have
another two hours down so that's one
game let's go to the next one so this is
a cool one so another way that you can
get tomorrow C is with this con con
variation some people call it Polson but
I think there is a little difference
between them
anyways con Polson so this is something
that's so asleep light just a few months
ago begins artemiev and so you see
you're getting the same pawn structure
again a little bit different because the
bishop comes out but see the pawns are
up there so if if black were to play
something like Bishop e7 or to try and
bring the bishop from the other side
it's the same pawn structure but the
ideas are slightly different and so we
get this nice C choose that nine cities
are also a pretty cool idea so you can
try to organize your attack with F form
all right I'm just showing you ideas and
another one to show is another game it's
been so on Artemia there is just a
slight difference
he put b6 and they got this kind of
development but again kind of a blitz
blitz tournament so not as not as how do
you say I was a thoughtful but that my
be the right word but okay so that was
another one let's look at another one
ooh I like this one
so Yasir played one of the native
Iranians Kamran Shirazi and that was
kind of cool because I liked singing
that and he they started to see for but
they landed on again mark see a little
different because the night came out of
that that way but pretty much same ideas
and you can already see that black is a
little struggling because he's not
following the typical typical routes and
so I wanted to share that as well now
let's get to the end games
shall we again I was just trying to show
you what is possible and what's not
possible and so hold on I think this
would be nope next one this would be our
first end game so see they started with
Knight f3 as well and then c4 and then
just switched it but we got to the same
exact position so there there's a line
that the Queen comes to a5 a little
earlier instead of like playing a6 and
rook c8 and that's usually when the
Knights have been exchanged on d4 and
you get this Knight d5 so maybe I'm
gonna pause a little second so you guys
could take a breather and I go take a
breather I was talking so fast and you
guys could try to absorb the position
and think a little about after Queen
exchange which pond do you want to take
with and why remember in the game that I
did I took it with E just because that's
in that specific position that was the
better idea and that I had the better
attack with my bishops but all right I'm
gonna see what's what's up in this
stream and the chat
do I play the Danish gambit that's
really maybe I should
and sorry I didn't see the question
because I was talking for a little too
fast
tactics well every game has a tactic
doesn't it okay yeah Paulson is a knight
on c6 yeah so earlier knight c6 would be
do I have examples against hey chog well
this is kind of that and that's my idea
that I had with Talia for Thursday in
ladies night stream and class to talk
more about what should black to 4h like
chalk yeah if I can say it
double isolated ponds
well thank you thank you all of you for
participating
wait who's Yasir no you didn't just ask
that you're messing with me aren't you
okay so
well taking over here is the most
accurate one but taking over a two is
also possible and this is kind of just
like again like one of the games that
was played just I'm just showing you for
the fun of it and it ended in a draw
because it's a kind of a weird and thing
to be honest but there's not much to it
so that is that's another thing to think
about the Queenie choose but between D
to King Gd - pretty much with whichever
you take it's a good idea for the end
game specifically to take with C to the
C pod because if Knight take he take
with seeing and you bring the rook and
attack and pawns and yay if you take
with Bishop I again take with C and now
what do you want to do with this
position like how do you want to bring
your pieces out
well good morning
Thomas
thank you - yeah it is kind of hard to
keep them both up
I mean to answer I cannot say that TRW
for war I think it kind of depends on
your preference
some people have Carrigan love French
love Alekhine anything so I really think
it depends on your personal ideas so
exchanging rooks well ideally you would
want your plan to take Europe so you can
take with the other Brooke and to
control the file so that's ideally what
you want it to happen but doesn't seem
like it's going to happen immediately so
what you can do is bring the bishop out
Bishop b2 is good I think Bishop d3 is
also good Bishop b5 I'm not I don't want
to give the a6 chances so I'm just gonna
go with Bishop e2 and push we push with
b4 so the idea is quite simple you want
to control everything you want to
control the Queen side you want to try
and control the Kings side you want to
control the center you are kind of
controlling the center you are kind of
controlling the Queen side enough much
is happening in the Kings side so your
Bishop is well placed over here your
bishop is okay placed on each you you
can't really do much about it but what
you can try to do is to try and maybe
relocate some of these rooks right so
black tries to bring the king you start
pushing with that side you push more now
you took all of the chances for the
Knights to get out here secant's gets
into these two squares and that's like
that's is a very good thing to have
so black tries to get a little creative
but wise manages to push up now we get
this Bishop teach you controlling the
square and you starts to dominate on the
Kings side you're fixing this side and
you finally bring out your other rook
push more pawns see everything is
controlled this Bishop is well ideally
you would want this Bishop to be more
active but this Bishop is controlling
everything now I'm gonna give you guys a
second to think about the endgame
because it's not a tactic not a tactical
and game it's more like you kind of
develop a feeling for what you're trying
to do and yeah because the pawn
structure is also kind of symmetrical
and pretty much White's advantage is all
about the space so pretty much the big
question here should be hard to use this
spatial advantage to convert it to a
full win so I do play a lot of scotch I
also play a lot sometimes Spanish Lopez
I like those mmm I have watched Star
Wars not the biggest fan but I have
watched it I dunno who ob1 here's rook -
D - yeah I don't get it
sorry guys
yeah pretty much to be shove on the
space so
exchanging the rooks is a little too
fast you would want to create more
weaknesses and some other holes and
stuff before you want to exchange your
looks off yes mark Marcin Bishop g4 good
good move proud of you now what do you
do
so maybe one of the things you can think
about is maybe am this route could be
somewhere better
I should have known that was a robot
boom oh no that's for future
Bishop Oh guys careful Bishop III you
get rocks III check bye-bye Bishop h4 h4
is coming up you don't want to do Bishop
d7 because the idea is that okay so
why's main idea is pressure all of these
games all of this pawn structure is
about pressure so you're putting
pressure pressure pressure tension until
your opponent breaks that's the biggest
idea in this in this endgame and so
that's why you go with drew kf1 and then
you push the pond and you push so it
doesn't seem like you're doing much or
your opponent is doing much but you are
you are pushing you are putting more
tension and more pressure so the
opponent is pretty much just moving the
bishop waiting to see what's going on
and now you do recatch one it is it is
possible to do Turkish one first and
then push so those of you who were
thinking about urkesh one and just
pushing the h-bond that is perfectly
fine - I haven't seen the opponent like
opponents last three moves see from here
to here no difference you just pushed
upon and you get this root K Street so
after work a stream you push a little
bit more you bring it here so now the
player idea is if what do you think
happens if Bishop goes to eight shades
yeah see the black king is collapsing
isn't it
well one thing is bhishan i8 is really
really weirdly placed so you could just
take it chill and just bring the bishop
out and try to create some stuff over
here that's one thing that you can do
because there is no more rooks III check
and black doesn't really have any decent
moves another thing that it is worth
considering but I wouldn't do it just
yet is to like exchange stuff off and go
to this route Kent game it is a very
interesting weekend game but the King is
more active but just compare this
position to this position you don't want
that you don't want to free your
opponent's pieces up right you don't
want to just exchange your good you
don't want to exchange your good pieces
off with your opponent's weirdly placed
pieces so officially shades I would
recommend to just chill for a second and
see what the opponent wants to do but so
in the game black white Bishop to a7
just because to control something in the
center and now white is playing so chill
it's actually a little knowing cuz
Bishop goes a little way you got Bishop
c3 just why it's like why would you even
need this Bishop to h3 right it's just
one of those super chill like I don't
need this right now moves and finally
you push for a 5 you take this guy
you give check and again such a chill
move you are just just just here not
doing like bishop just protecting your
pawn see and if Bishop tries to go back
to g1 what it took in d7 and black
resigned
I assume the resignation was mainly due
to woody what are you gonna do next
there's check
there's a bunch of other checks over
here and if you come up I can just try
to go for this pawn see this is a
deadpan and after that that's a
full/queen so yeah that was one of the
interesting ones a five-week f3 yep
they're all good moves and it's just
yeah that's something like Magnus does
just put pressure put pressure and the
opponent brakes yep all right I'm glad
you guys like this next one let me just
double check that this is the right yep
it's the right one because there are a
bunch of the end games so that's
hopefully we can get through some of it
alright so say this started with Knights
f3 and then c4 as well and now we are
getting to our usual Maroussi setup
Queen comes to a5 faster you do the f3
you protect your pawns and then you do
this 95
and now we got pretty much same position
structure at least same as last one
so if you were to take with this pawn b5
is kind of annoying and you don't really
know your pawns are kind of wiggling a
little so that's why I taking with the C
pawn is better so no let's say Knight
goes away you push for b4 so you take
away this critical c5 square and for
example King tries to come closer you
start pushing the pawn again like in the
last one and next you get your a5
candiate now what do you think White's
should do so I'm gonna go look up the
chat a little
yeah h6 is a baby queen what was Thank
You Patricia and Magnus would be proud
don't rush why yeah he does say that too
I think everybody say that but yeah that
is true thank you I think I do have an
endgame of old Fenderson prepares to
show you - well I stream to midnight so
we can say happy birthday well you can
say it already because technically I was
born in Iran and I already have my
birthday so you can't say that if you
want to I see Tracy walking here and
shaking her head
thank you for looking from Poland
[Music]
do I recommend mark CS best well I feel
like it really depends on your personal
style but my personal style is that I
really like to attack and puts pressure
so that's something that I really like
and that's why I like choose this pawn
structure with marks and all thank you
Tim Olson thank you everyone
okay so yeah one of the things that's
possible to consider is this f4 mainly
because well seal asking last game the
king was kind of more active so the rip
could try and jump around right now the
rook is stuck with this pawn so that's
something that white could try to
improve so F for let's say e6 now see
black is trying to play a little more
decisive rather than the last game where
blacks just keep playing bishop back and
forth now you try to you see right now
black tries to like activate the King
but gave this pin for a brief second now
what do you want to do with whites
yes that is true Marty :
Matsuri metrics oh I just watched the
movie matrix so matrix trauma that is
true it is easy to remember not not this
year taxi or Doh haha so yeah basically
what do you want to do right now as
white
mr. Vishwa is interesting but think
about something more pushy pushy
so Bishop h4 is a nice idea and you're
gonna use it to get something out of the
position but nots right away
oh yay Thank You Julio Julio sorry
pronunciations be five so the idea is
pretty simple if you take over here you
get that pissed you get pissy [ __ ]
fourth and you lose your hook if you
take here you again get this picture
which Forbush everyone bye bye Bishop so
that's why I taking doesn't work so the
only two moves that are worth
considering is night moving and g5 to
stop the check right so let's look at
Knights moving away first now what do
you want to do with white
if you find the correct sequence of
moves two moves and you have clear
advantage
oh so b5 yes and notes do something
first then b5 yes Bishop e6 first oops
Bishop e6 first then b5 yeah this is
pretty cool right so see if you were to
take over here Bishop b4 and this is
black is holding if you were to play
like Bishop e1 this is a like a draw
super drop so we don't want that so the
most accurate one is to check first and
pushed upon so the problem the big
problem is if you take take move the
King there's always this Bishop D fours
and the rookies the bishop is pinned to
the rook and you can't really do that so
what about g5 what do you want to do
with White's after g5
thank you for all of you who are sending
suggestions and recommendations
yep bye-bye bishop so what about
hereafter g5 no more Bishop H force so
how do you want to win this to be fair
you already do have advantage but it is
important to try and use it so basically
how are you gonna try and use this
advantage etext e6 is a nice idea what
else
fg5 okay Bishop g4 nice f5 um alright so
let's let's look at taking over here
what do you think is Black's best move
so
[Music]
in the game black took bishop before and
after rooks got exchanged now what do
you want to do so now we all you all
have probably heard a lot that's two
bishops really really love open center
and this is pretty much open center so
how are you going to use this and use
this advantage of two bishops and your
possible past Panzano maybe
yes good job Bishop d3 if Knight takes
on e5 you just take over there and
question what if Knight goes to f8 would
you do now
yep what do you do after a night of
fades ah be careful
maybe give me a full line
guys always think about takes first
takes and well checks first but there's
no real checks here so checks takes
moves with threats I have seen few of
you say the correct move so yes thank
you Marcin take and g6 and Queen can't
stop it
that was a full grown Queen I was gonna
call it a baby queen but around here is
a baby queen right so after Knight takes
e5 Bishop h7 let's say Knights goes to
g4 how are you gonna try and wrap this
game up almost done so how
ten keyword explaination Elio
yeah pretty cool huh so how do you want
to wrap this one up maybe it's a little
bit more support before you start push
the pond
yeah this shove d4 good job you guys
so if King goes to d8 you just simply
push the key push the night away and
just no rush
see now the knight is trapped you
already know even if you forget to push
your palms or something
you're still pretty cool you are winning
and if e5 just give a check and this is
also winning because you can just pick
this guy up or you could just give it
another check over here if the King goes
to d8 if the King goes to b8 so many
ways to win you can take this push win
so yeah that was another game let's look
at another game I want to look at the
under son game or a carpool fun which
one do you want to carpool fun yeah
let's do the carpet fun and they can
look at the old Fenderson game Thursday
so yeah hopefully we'll be able to put
up a votes again like last time for
Thursday to continue with Mormo Roxy and
see how that goes so you guys can have a
better understanding and I can show you
more and more games and end games and
just different ways to get to maroc see
so this is again you're getting to my
Roxy's stuff see a little difference cuz
we've looked at the do show on e3 so far
but Karpov played Bishop g5 and well Who
am I to tell carpet fighter boy
casteau Queen d2 one thing to keep in
mind this is usually see right now
there's no real danger of knights doing
anything weird to anywhere but after
castle the there is a danger of not
starting to jump around so that's why
after the bishop is protected by the
castle you move your queen away
after Bishop e6 rooks t125 seen you get
that clean coming out again quickly you
get that f3 again and in this little
different structure over here so cargo
played light a four instead of Knight d5
which is still pretty good doable
nothing wrong with it and after Queens
exchanged he got rook c6 so yeah how do
you guys want to continue with this
what are your options haven't really
fully decided yet I that's one of the
options we can't do more strategy
because one of my favorites there is
this one specific game in a book called
Giants of strategy that I absolutely
love it's called how to beat Kasparov in
13 steps and I will show that game to
you guys at some point but we could do
two hours of like strategy different
types of strategy just trying to cover
as much as we can or we could continue
doing mark C or any different if you
have different opening suggestions leave
it in the comments after and look those
up
so yep 93 good one
93 and 95 now what do you think black
should do it's blacks to move black has
the option of taking or not
thank you Bob
oh thank you mark and Marcin okay so in
the game
the he plays King f8 but taking on d5 is
also interesting but now you would take
with the other pawn
just because you push the Rick to go to
c7 and it's already more pleasant and
you already have and have an age on
pushing pawns so that's something that
you could consider now king of 8 now
what do you want to do just because like
we want we've seen two to three
different end games that we saw with
this Bishop taking d5 see d5 and
everything was set to go what about now
oh I thank you thank you Zippo
okay so Bishop III is the interesting
one you're gonna go use these holes as
mentioned earlier in the chat thank you
so 97 is kind of like automatic response
because if you don't want to take on d5
and you're not you haven't taken so far
you're not gonna take it - and see the
problem is after 97 your knight is
leaving the center so it gives some
ideas to start pushing stuff over here
like h4 take now you take with the e
because if you take with the C there are
just nasty oxytrees and also right now
your game is decided to be more in the
king side with a hands on the Queen side
if possible to start pushing like P 4 P
5 etc so your game is in the Kings side
your next move is going to be a spy G
for a for push push push
so that's why when you're going to do
King side attack it's better to have
these kind of pawn structure when Queen
side attack the other side the other
take with seat basically so now let's
say what goes a little back which is
pretty much the only move h4 h5 but
sorry I've been talking a little too
fast and King g8 you push f4 f4 is the
most accurate cuz you take away this
Aoife a square from the night tonight
goes to c5 you bring out the bishop
check King up for example f5 Bishop
comes back now you want to eat a pawn so
let's say your opponent plays b5 what do
you do this is another critical moment
and let's see if you can play like
Karpov
so have I ever played the four player
just I tried that a little it was a
little not small not my most favorites
so h6 interesting but the most
interesting is g4
why do you think g4 is more interesting
hi parts so funny story right now I'm
supposed to be an organic chemistry
tutor and I forgot about it
so my friend / tutor is here oops
what did I study in college I'm studying
biology and health sciences and and in
pre-med so okay so g4 is cool mainly
because if taking you just take back and
so remember how I told you most of these
end games is just about the pressure
pressure pressure so the pressure is on
see ya ji fork just increases the
pressure it's not like you're going to
actually take and lose the piece so
that's why it's better to just bring
more pressure and I if you take on c4
great Hui exchange a pair of rooks up
and now there is a still pressure I am
going to try and attack your pawns and
that's why blacks just play tonight c5
after Knight c5 Bishop takes e5 let's
say rook takes so taking back on c5 is
one of those moves that you try to avoid
but it's necessary because if you start
moving your King you're losing Tempe and
then this pawn is weak and your opponent
gets a chance to start jumping around so
that is why it's a good idea to just
take take and now h6 I remember earlier
in the stream and I mean the chats I
read about h6 and everyone was like oh
h6 well h6 is the cool move black white
Bishop f8 and now King c3 g5 is also
another good idea but after okay five
only if you play rook e1 not
just don't care about the pawn rook b1
and go for the pawn exchange rook
exchange and if rook takes you just
pushed upon C cool tactics huh huh so
who said there are no tactics here so
but Karpov decided to play King c3 and
now C so I'm sure a lot of you have
heard about the different colored bishop
the opposite colored bishop and games
even though the material is equal white
is winning because this bishop is just a
weird top on the bishop doesn't have
anywhere to go and that's one of the big
reasons that you have to really be
careful on what you're trying to achieve
so like you've heard about this the
opposite colored bishop is a draw but
that's not true it's not a draw every
every position is different so you bring
in more pressure you go after that
that's beautiful pawn and you are still
keeping the pressure on now what do you
want to do with white
so
um yes h7 now what do you think is
Black's best defense it's the last
question I'm gonna ask you okay not
really
but one of the last questions I'm gonna
ask you for today
so let me tell you what is wrong first
so with white if so if it's white
similar was just a queen and voila if
Bishop g7 yes you do take on d5 and the
pressure is still very high and you just
simply try and bring in your king see
you fix everything over there bring in
the King and that's actually how Karpov
won the game so the game is over but I
wanted to show you what is black space
move because Bishop g7 was a losing move
so Bishop g7 we just saw Bishop 67 you
bring in the King and win but if h7 rook
takes c4 King D 3 now Bishop g7 now what
do you do that's why you should always
think about Czechs first you should try
to train yourself always give the check
first think about X and then the
defenses or they the attacks like
defense like Bishop g7 yep that is
pretty much correct too with the what
fragrance just set
so that is why well if you play Queen
right now it's not going to work cause
root c8 and it's a draw it
it's a draw because King g7 is coming up
and you're gonna lose the bit the piece
so that's why you play Bishop D said
taking the pond first rook c5 and now
what do you try to do you try to bring
in the bishop but white still holds
advantage but it's not as clear as a win
as it was with Bishop g7 so Bishop which
8 and again it is
still good position it is still doable
winnable but let's say we catch five
what do you do you see it's getting a
little weird even Bishop h8 even Bishop
h8 it's not as easy you see the king is
too far for cash 5 is possible but I
still really like this Rakesh 5 right
here because it's my key you either
taking it or you don't take it but like
right now if you're just holding on
you could try to bring in some King and
maybe take take well yeah I don't think
this is a winning anymore it's white
still has the upper hand but not winning
so just wrap up h7 carbs opponent
carbolic played Bishop g7 which resulted
in Bishop d5 and C blacks just made
lifes White's life I'm a lot easier by
not taking the c4 pawn and that's my
biggest advice don't make your life's
opponent your opponent's life easy over
the chessboard just try to find the
moves that makes it harder and harder
for your opponents and I think that's
that is one of the biggest things that
I've learned in chess and I try to apply
it in all of my chess games and I hope
you guys enjoyed the maroc c series that
we did today for the openings and how we
can get to those openings and how to
play with the endgame I think the most
understanding that the understanding
situation was which pawn to take with
and I think I hope you guys enjoyed it
hopefully we'll do a poll and we'll see
if you guys want to hear more of Mark C
on Thursday or you prefer to do more
strategy of middle game slash and
and yeah exactly my life's not going to
be as easy when I actually have to study
organic chemistry again all right I wish
you all the best and I'm gonna go try to
find a cake and celebrate my birthday
okay see you all later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you